he's the highest paid employee in our  federal government  and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr  fauci began to set national policy that  affected the way that 330 million  americans lived their lives for goodness  sakes i'm telling you wear a mask keep  social distancing there's nothing  political about that but who is anthony  fauci people who have conspiracy  theories those are people that don't  particularly care for me in this short  series we will do what the establishment  media have refused to do  we will give you an unvarnished look at  the career of the most powerful  politician in america  dr anthony thatcher don't you think it's  time that you step down and let someone  else who has a more effective message  actually no